ah
e
y nada más
[Música]
gracias por permitirme
formar parte de un pedazo de su vida
gracias por prestarme sus oídos y
gracias gracias por esta bella
invitación
la verdad es que
escribí como como 15 mensajes para
con esta plática
y ninguno terminó por darme la paz que
necesitaba
hasta que logré escribir uno que de
alguna u otra manera no nada más me hizo
sentirme en paz sino me hizo sentir gozo
hace tres días antes de llegar a esta
plática mi vida cambió por completo
llegó un suceso a mi vida del cual les
voy a platicar más adelante que sin duda
ha cambiado un poco la historia de mi
vida antes de comenzar
me gustaría platicarles un poco acerca
de mí qué es lo que hago no tengo un
título ni tengo un diplomado por si
esperaban un doble doctorado a un tipo
extremadamente letrado pero lo que sí sé
es que algunos lo certifican de escuela
y a otros nos certifica la vida
y la realidad es que cómo tratas a un
mesero me habla más de tu educación que
todos tus títulos y todos tus doctorados
no hay genios muy miserables y educados
pues muy pobres también pero pero bueno
mi nombre es también la vida tengo 33
años soy el cuarto hijo de una familia
divorciada padre ingeniero naval madre
comerciante
y comencé a trabajar desde los 6 años
casi casi desde que era un feto
más o menos por ahí y para los que ya me
están viendo con cara de ay pobrecito su
mamá lo explotada este siempre dio su
niñez
y si por ahí aparece la primera es soy
yo
seis años a jane bowles comencé a
trabajar en la televisión desde muy
chiquitito por eso trabajan los seis
años literal por una gran coincidencia
aunque hoy 28 años después
comprendo que eso no fue una
coincidencia sino un proceso que tarde o
temprano se activó en mi vida
y tenía seis años
a los 12 años ya había hecho más de 640
comerciales ser uno de los personajes
que más comerciales había hecho en aquel
entonces
en ese momento sin lugar a dudas creo
que a todos nos ha pasado hay vidas que
son un ejemplo y hay vidas que son una
advertencia cierto
pero hay que aprender de ambas de alguna
u otra manera
continué trabajando en ese ínter y se
comerciales películas telenovelas
desfiles estudia actuación pantomima
arte y demás cuando cumplí 18 años
decidí irme a vivir solo por supuesto ya
llevaba años trabajando decidí irme a
vivir solo porque me enamoré de una
mujer 12 años más grande que yo
y esta es mi esposa con la cual llevo 15
años actualmente continuo con ella
decidí a enamorarme de ella de hecho
creo que su mejor escote siempre fue su
cerebro
así que chicas muestren lo que funciona
y funciona muy bien
estaba enamorada de gracias
[Aplausos]
mi esposa en aquel entonces andaba con
un argentino pero este argentino estaba
muy enfocado en el fútbol y que estaba
muy enfocado en su vieja
a la baja quien tiene tienda que la
tienda es la realidad te das cuenta mi
amor por ahí está en el público la vida
ha dado muchas vueltas y gracias a dios
ella las ha dado conmigo
la guerra continuó y seguir con mi hobby
seguir trabajando continua enamorándome
de ella 31 veces al mes después quise
ser rock star
jajaja
pero me ofrezco en españa me firmaron en
una disquera después tuve que pagar 350
mil pesos para que me dejaran salir de
la disquera
fue terrible pero eso sí me la pasé
bomba como restarle sentían rey lagarto
y toda la onda aunque con esa camisa yo
creo que morrison se hubiera dado un
balazo otra vez extra pero bueno
deje por completo el tema de la música
lo que en algunos lugares interesantes
aunque el myspace nos iba cabrón no
nunca nos imaginamos que myspace iba a
quebrar entonces las cosas no fueron tan
bien en aquel entonces la verdad es que
me empezó a ir muy mal económicamente
andaba muy roto y para la industria la
que yo me dedico la verdad es que es una
industria bellísima pero muy cruel no la
verdad es que uno siempre tiene que
estar picando piedra como en todo la
verdad como como en la vida por lo por
lo regular la verdad es que me está
yendo tan mal que pase de rockstar a
paletero
me puse a hacer paletas con alcohol
recuerdo que junté 40.000 vanos y abrir
un local que estaba muy cerca de la
universidad y tan no
y puse mi local ahí afuera y vaciando
las paletas con mi esposa mi cuñado y
mejor amigo y me cogieron los chavos de
la tarde siempre fueron así esta
durísima la vivió así de
venga que parece rock star a paletero
compra de mis socios te vas a dar cuenta
de que se trata de que te gradúas y deja
que te cases no
después de ser paletero
empezó un programa de televisión el cual
ganaba muy poco barro pero la verdad me
divertía muchísimo porque termina siendo
lo que más hago que es hablar terminé
entrevistando a grandes artistas y
semanal de entrevistas de mil
entrevistas viaje por toda latinoamérica
por europa entero y de pronto enrique
iglesias que donde estaba solo nadie
nunca me supo responder
a pitbull le dije que no más futurista
sino más me tocó trabajar con artistas
nacionales internacionales y con fire on
file y otros hip hoperos demasiado
interesantes esta cara cansada ha tenido
muchas fiestas familia
después arme una productora una
productora de espectáculos termina
siendo más de 650 conciertos para más de
300.000 personas vendí más de 2 millones
de tickets en un negocio en el único
negocio donde tú pagas y no mandas el
que mandes el artista es la realidad
porque los artistas tienen como hipo
emocional no son como tripolar es
entonces que hoy estoy triste estoy
cansado hoy no quiero cantar entonces
será un verdadero reto trabajar en la
industria de la televisión después puse
una discoteca en la discoteca terminó
abriendo el club dita von teese y jack
white llegó ese día a tomar no sé qué
hacía ahí yo no lo invité por no lo
conozco pero pero y estaba y bueno hasta
hasta hace poco
mi vida empezó a cambiar en el 2016
comencé a tener unos dolores muy graves
como sea tener una vida difícil me
duelen las articulaciones grandes
dolores de cabeza muchísimo cansancio
depresión en mi de que para que yo me
deprima está cañón o sea esa es la
realidad
resulta que me fui a hacer unos exámenes
y un día antes de irme a mi road trip
manual con mi mujer en esta ocasión nos
llevamos de los ángeles hasta vancouver
más de 2000 kilómetros y vamos a
recorrer
me habló la doctora conteste el teléfono
y me dijo lanier como está ha sido con
buenas tardes doctora oye quiero decirte
que tienes line this is que es una
bacteria es una enfermedad ahí es una
bacteria súper poderosa súper
inteligente y la edad esa garrapata
que está ahí y obviamente mi carácter
me voy mañana de vacaciones esto es lo
único que pude pensar es como yo no voy
a cancelar mi viaje dijo la doctora y me
puedo ir de viaje y dijo bueno pues eso
lo decides tú depende de cómo te sientas
no la verdad es que me fui me valió un
pepino me fui de vacaciones regresé
comencé mi tratamiento y la verdad es
que dije bueno ahora que sé que tengo
una bacteria dentro de mi cuerpo ejemplo
le voy a hacer la vida de cuadritos por
completo esta bacteria no porque a estar
de nuevo a vivir en la mente en el
cuerpo de un güey tan positivo como yo
fracasaste como bacteria gruesa
para casarse como bacteria brother
[Aplausos]
increíble la verdad increíble porque la
doctora mi hijo daniel lleva cinco años
enfermo y lo tienes en el cerebro dijo
bota esta pobrecita de estar frustrada y
macao nuestra décima de hecho yo creo
que ahí la epigenética sin lugar a duda
me da la razón a mí y soy una
comprobación que el dogma central es una
verdadera falacia sin lugar a dudas
somos lo que pensamos sin lugar a duda
la vida se acciona de acuerdo a tus
decisiones pensamientos equivocados
generan emociones equivocadas emociones
equivocadas generan caminos equivocados
estos mismos hábitos equivocados son los
que terminan por destruir tu vida la
gente me dice que es muy difícil cambiar
y yo la verdad es que me cago de risa
porque es la verdadera mentira lo
difícil es comprenderlo estúpidamente
fácil que es cambiar cuando estaba
escribiendo esta bella plática para
ustedes
recibí una de las peores llamadas que
pude haber recibido que cualquier ser
humano desde mi punto de vista puede
recibir hace tres días literal antes de
estar aquí con ustedes sonó el teléfono
en la madrugada respondía el teléfono y
la noticia era ola de miel papá falleció
con el teléfono hace 3 días
lloré grité pero como estaba tan cansado
estaba tan cansado y como me no me gusta
hacer las cosas a medias y ejecuta si
voy a llorar me voy a quedar para
agarrar fuerzas y llorar como se bebe
como realmente se debe llorar porque soy
un apasionado de todo lo que hago y no
me gusta hacer las cosas mediocremente
porque yo creo que la ignorancia y la
mediocridad son las peores enfermedades
de este mundo no matan más gente que
decide llegar ser la gente se suicida
simplemente por ignorantes o por
mediocres el chiste es que me dormí
desperté y lloré grité todo lo que tenía
que hacer recordé dije me voy a dormir
porque realmente la noche se hizo para
descansar no para sufrir realmente no
importa qué es lo que estés pasando qué
es lo que está sufriendo por más que
llores por más que barry de si no te
duermes va a cambiar es la realidad el
punto es que empezó a sonar mi celular
empezó a sonar la verdad es que no
quería hablar absolutamente con nadie
había miles y miles de llamadas perdidas
hasta que me di cuenta que había 12
llamadas perdidas de una de las personas
que más amo en mi vida
decidí marcarle a pesar de cómo me
sentía
le marqué
empezó a llorar
estaba llorando esta persona que me
contestó del otro del lado del teléfono
lloraba y lloraba y lloraba y decía yo
estoy peor entonces lo único que pude
decirle a mi amiga le dije mira si no
dejas de llorar te voy a colgar el
teléfono
dijo perdón perdón es que no sé cómo
controlar mis sentimientos no sé cómo
controlar mis emociones limpia me
importa un pepino simplemente aseguran
te voy a colgar el teléfono dejó de
llorar en ese momento y pasó de estar
muy triste estar muy en cámara nada
conmigo
le dije ves te diste cuenta como si
puedes dejar de estar triste nada más
que ahora decidiste estar encabronada
ahora qué harías si te digo que si
sigues encabronar conmigo si te voy a
colgar de forma obviamente empezó a
morirse de la risa empezó a morir de la
risa y en ese mismo momento me di cuenta
que la única manera de acabar con el
dolor del ser humano es no nada más
pensando en tu dolor sino pensando en el
dolor de los demás
fue ahí en donde me di cuenta que había
desaparecido mi dolor en un simple
segundo cuando únicamente lo que hice
fue cambiar la pregunta de cómo me ayudó
a cómo la ayudó es que de verdad familia
si únicamente en la vida se trata de
nosotros jamás vamos a poder crear
relaciones que sean realmente duraderas
si realmente toda la vida se trata de
nosotros vamos a estar completamente
equivocados en cada paso que vemos ahí
es ahí es en donde me di cuenta que
podía desaparecer mi dolor hay miles y
miles de libros de autoayuda se dan
cuenta pero no hay libros de ayuda a los
demás
todos nosotros queremos ayudarnos a
nosotros y eso de primero ayudarte tú y
después a ayudar a los demás les prometo
que está rotundamente equivocado cuando
comienzas a ayudar a los demás aunque tú
estés podrido roto triste
deprimido la vida comienza a cambiar por
completo no se trata de ti la vida la
vida se trata de servir se trata de
servir a los demás si bien es esta vida
y lo único que haces es servirte a ti
mismo estarás completamente equivocado
la vida
no se trata de ti se trata de los demás
todos los que estamos aquí sentados
hemos pasado por el valle del dolor pero
simplemente algunos de ustedes han
decidido construir una residencia en
este valle yo lo único que hice de tres
días para acá fue levantar mi carpa y
continuar mi camino y por favor no me
digas que danielle aquí solamente se te
ocurrió tu papá a mi me asesinaron a
toda mi familia perdí me violaron le
dejó perdónenme siempre hay un tiempo
para recuperarlo todo todos los que
estamos aquí un día hemos tenido el peor
día de nuestra vida pero también un día
vamos a tener el mejor día de nuestra
vida si tú has perdido todo el día de
hoy aún te queda una vida completa para
recuperarlo todo cierto
sé que allá afuera hay miles de héroes
silenciosos
yo la verdad es que prefiero en la gente
que tiene más ganas que excusas
la gente hoy por hoy no quiere ser
exitosa lo que la gente quiere ser muy
famosa y déjame decirte que los
followers no te quitan lo pedante
errores ni la ropa cara te quita lo
barato
la realidad es que la gente piensa que
porque sienten los flechazos en la cara
se está dirigiendo en el camino correcto
y está rotundamente equivocada el
verdadero éxito en esta vida es cumplir
tu propósito para lo que fuiste hecho no
hay nada más difícil en este mundo que
tratar de ser alguien que no eres has
visto esta gente que son como alebrijes
no que respetaban hacer pesas con bauer
aquí está esta gente
sí sí sí tienen el mercedes pero no para
la gas esta gente citado sitio ha
comentado temprano se temen los cielos
tarde o temprano se temen 200 es la
realidad
son como three polares 4 y polares pero
no hay nada más poderoso en esta vida
que ser quien realmente eres tu propia
unicidad que no te das cuenta que no hay
nadie como tú en el universo entero en
toda la materia de este universo no hay
nadie como tú y de verdad que no tengo
ganas ni de motivar tener inspirarte la
realidad es que me motivo yo solo y eso
inspira a otros hong kong pero la
motivación no sirve de nada porque te
motivas un lunes y el jueves entras otra
vez deprimido la vida es una es
la realidad pero si no hay una verdadera
inspiración si no hay una verdadera
convicción en esta vida estamos
dirigidos por las opiniones por las
creencias y por las convicciones las
opiniones se diluyen no te das cuenta
que existe una opinión de mí después
empiezas a crearte una creencia y
después empiezas a tener una convicción
yo estoy dispuesto a morir por mis
convicciones es que en esta vida no se
trata de qué tan duro lo intentas
sirve que lo intentes hasta que lo
consigas es la realidad
es la verdadera realidad
si tus metas son muy grandes
por favor no se las menos olas con esa
mentes pequeñas que no te das cuenta que
ideas redondas no caben en mentes
cuadradas que no
simplemente no cuadra no entra aprende
por favor a comer en banquetas y en
banquetes
no sirve de nada tener mucho dinero se
entiende es mucho dinero tienes mente de
pobre el dinero notará rico juego esa es
la realidad la gente sigue y continúa
persiguiendo la riqueza y la riqueza
materiales también es una delicia pero
qué tal si buscáramos la prosperidad
muchachos la prosperidad en todos los
sentidos el verdadero problema del ser
humano ni siquiera es económico ni
siquiera es profesional ni siquiera es
emocional es 100% espiritual es la
realidad la gente siempre anda buscando
con qué llenar algo
siempre vamos a tener un vacío porque
estamos tienes hoy aquí porque vienen
buscando una respuesta perdón de la vida
se trata más de preguntas más que de
respuestas se trata más de perder que de
ganar una relación un matrimonio una
amistad se trata más de perder se trata
más de quién eres tú para que ella sea
yo llevo 15 años con mi mujer y en mi
matrimonio el que pierde más rápido gana
porque si ella pierde y yo pierdo la
relación gana si pierde el jefe y pierde
los empleados gana la compañía
esta vida no se trata de lo que tú
quieres la mayoría de ustedes tienen un
listado de deseos yo deseo ser rico yo
deseo ser famoso yo deseo tener una
compañía yo deseo yo deseo tus deseos me
valen madre
tus convicciones brother porque estás
dispuesto a morir que va a decir aunque
va a decir tú lápida aquí sigue
descansando nos
aquí sigue el huevón zazo este no
llama decir tú la vida ya te lo has
puesto a pregunta ya te lo has
preguntado ya tienes esa respuesta
porque si no tienes esa respuesta
perdóname habrás conseguido el éxito
pero no habrás conseguido la paz del
gozo
estás siguiendo
y para aquellos que creen que deberíamos
de vivir un museo de santos perfectos y
de diamantes sin manchas señores todos
los que estamos aquí estamos rotos y
estamos podridos
todos todos por favor no yo sé que
algunos de ustedes son los que nos está
viendo en internet a decir aires
yo podría decirlo ese huevito dice lo
mismo que dicen miles de libros y bueno
pero la verdad es que hay gente hay
gente que quiere que los demás hagan lo
que ellos no se atreven a hacer esa es
la realidad el amor le que el juicio en
la casa de la burla vive la estupidez es
la realidad pero como nos encanta
enjuiciar nos encanta poner estereotipos
qué pasaría si todos ahorita nos
amáramos no te das cuenta del buey que
está a tu lado y de la charla que está a
tu lado y nada más la perfección mira
nada más que le hiciese a mano pensando
en más la perfección de máquina que
tienes a tu alrededor y tú sigues sin
sorprenderte de la vida te atreves a
estar deprimido realmente necesitas
motivación que estar vivo no es
suficiente para ti
primero
al la crisis
estoy deprimido de una conferencia ante
3000 jóvenes la semana pasada y un chavo
17 años me dice daniel yo me siento
fracasado
libro de tus prepárate para que te tumbe
los dientes la vida porque todavía no
sabes de qué se trata vas a llorar vas a
sufrir pero qué bueno que vas a sufrir
porque si lloras si no aprendes habrá
llorado en vano pero el dolor no es una
herramienta de destrucción es una
herramienta de construcción querido deja
de tener miedo la gente tiene más miedo
a vivir que a morir el miedo no existe
muchachos el miedo es simplemente un
truco muy bien logrado
todos todos necesitamos aplausos todos
necesitamos reconocimiento todos todos
hacemos las cosas por vanidad hoy usted
está aquí para ver si aprende
podría hacerlo mejor
y está bien
o bien
creo en la vida
alguna vez has visto una carroza fúnebre
con alhajas de una casa así mientras que
la van arrastrando nunca es la realidad
porque estoy yo aquí arriba porque yo lo
único que quiero es llegar venir y
decirte que aunque estés completamente
roto aunque hayas estado en el peor día
de tu vida un día todo va a estar bien
lo que se fue no hace falta y lo que
hace falta ya vendrá
aquí te afanas si el mañana en mañana no
te pertenece de mañana ni es tuyo el
mañana es solamente el asesino de tus
sueños mañana cambio mañana lo hago
ahorita
a ese riesgo
pero si las leyes y si dos de ellos por
ejemplo hoy viera el gimnasio no fui con
la
un listado de deseos convicciones en
esta vida hay que cambiar por completo e
hicieron por él tengo que hay lo daniel
de su misión obligación pues por eso
estúpidos
a mí no me gusta no me gusta que me
obliguen
hay cosas que tienes que hacer no quiero
comer pues tienes que comer
no quiero dormir pues tienes que dormir
es que no quiero salir de la depresión
pues tienes que salir de la depresión
nadie nadie en esta en esta vida puede
señalar t
nadie queridos apasiona viva tu vida
la compasión la auto destruye por
completo
te destruye por completo
la mejor idea que te puedo dar la mejor
idea que te puedo dar es ama
ama cada vez que puedas y la verdad es
que siempre puedes
siempre puedes perdonar
deja de ser como es mi goma
my day es que no sé cómo perdonarlo es
que no se me hizo tanto daño a ti lo que
te hicieron es que te lastimaron delegó
güey
a ti te lastimaron el ego es por eso que
vives en la soberbia es por eso que
vives en el dolor es por eso que vives
en la humillación espiritual porque no
has dejado ese dolor
perdónate libérate el perdón es un
regalo para ti no para los demás es la
verdadera llave a la libertad que voy a
hacer yo si yo voy a volver a ver a mi
padre yo voy a volver a casarme con él y
terminaré aquella plática sobre los
espartanos y el imperio persa que un día
lo voy a volver a ver y qué hago
reclamar la vida porque te lo llevaste
porque me lo quita
ya estamos grandecitos no
es tiempo de verdaderamente crecer la
madurez no es tener dinero la madurez no
es tener casas la madurez es dar frutos
cuáles son los frutos qué frutos son los
que tienes en tu vida son dulces o son
amargos
si te tuvieras que comer sus palabras te
envenenar y has de nutrir y has cómo
estás caminando la vida
de nada sirve que vengas y aprendas en
estas pláticas y allá fuera no hagas
nada esta vida no necesita grandes
pensadores necesita grandes hacedores
está roto pero no necesitas que nadie te
arregle todos los que estamos aquí
estamos rotos pero si nos unimos en un
solo cuerpo nadie nos puede romper
porque lo que está quebrado nadie lo
puede quebrar de nuevo
gracias
te lo digo en serio te amo
te bendigo y no me importa que no te
conozco
yo estoy para servirte y tú debes estar
para servir a quien realmente te
necesitan
muchas gracias
o
[Música]